- So what I'm going to do
is ask all y'all to think of
what you'd like a rap about.
- [Male Audience Member 1] Jews for Jesus.
- Jews for Jesus?
(audience laughs and claps)
Okay.
So I often, quite often, like,
I'll record these and post them online.
Let's not do it, this, for this one.
I'll get myself tremendously canceled.
But Jews for Jesus.
Yeah.
Okay, cool.
So let's come to this,
this kind of wedge from
the front to the back-
- [Female Audience Member 1] Walmart!
- [Male Audience Member 2] Dust Bowl!
- So, so. What, what is it?
You said Walmart, and what did you say?
- [Male Audience Member 2] The Dust Bowl.
- Okay. A Walmart in the Dust Bowl.
Nice.
(audience laughs)
Okay.
Let's come to you guys over here
and then we'll bounce back to the middle.
So if you're kind of, you know,
in this area here, it's
kind of a bit dark,
but what we would you like a rap about?
- [Male Audience Member 3] Beef science.
(laughter erupts from audience)
- Just to clarify, I think
that person said beef science.
Is that?
(audience laughs)
Cool.
Is that something you've made up?
(audience laughs)
- [Male Audience Member 4] South End.
- South End? What is that in
reference to beef science?
You mean the, the, the British
seaside town of South End?
No one's going to enjoy
that bit of the rap.
I've never been to South End as it sounds,
it sounds terrible.
So wait, what, what did you say, my name?
Is that Will?
Yeah, Will.
What'd you want a rap about?
Will always does,
I don't want you to think this is prepped.
Like, I'm like, hey,
Will shout out some shit.
Will always tries to fuck me up. Okay.
So, so far we have Jews for
Jesus, Dust Bowl Walmart,
beef science.
So far,
you guys have done a really
good job of fucking me up.
(audience laughs)
Will, yeah.
I love it as well. Everyone is like,
"Oh, we bought tickets.
It should be our go."
No, Will, what do you want a rap about?
- [Will] Solar powered flashlights.
- Solar Powered.
Yeah. I mean, they exist though.
You know, they exist, Will?
- [Will] Yeah, but not during the day.
(audience laughs)
- Will's not heard of a
thing called batteries.
Do you think like,
solar powered calculators,
where people like.
I don't know. Okay, cool.
Solar powered flashlights. Great.
Cool.
I'll take it in the
spirit it was intended,
which is, it sounds absurd.
And then let's get one final one.
This can come from anywhere
and it just has to be good.
- [Male Audience Member
5] East Hampton moms.
- Okay, I heard two. Did
you say "East Hampton mum"?
- [Male Audience Member 5] Yes!
- And what did you say, in the back?
- [Female Audience Member
2] I said Afghanistan.
- Oh.
(audience laughs)
Okay.
Well, I mean,
seeing as we're already not
going to put this online
because of that guy.
Yeah.
Sorry, East Hampton mom.
But Afghanistan it is.
(audience laughs)
Okay.
Well, let's, let's have fun with this.
My band are gonna, it's been,
cause it's been two months
since we met together.
So let's, let's have some fun with this.
(band starts singing vocals)
Okay. To remind you it's
Jews for Jesus, beef science,
Walmart Dustbowl, Afghanistan.
And remind me of this one that we had?
Yep.
- [Audience] Solar powered flashlights!
- Solar powered flashlights. Yeah.
Now I've got it. Nice.
Cool.
♪ Started off kind of ironic, it's night ♪
♪ Still Will at the side ♪
♪ Shouting out the flashlight ♪
♪ That's a torch in the UK ♪
♪ I know that you say slightly different ♪
♪ A torch, like the wood with the flame ♪
♪ But I'm talking about the Maglites ♪
♪ I'll pick it up, I'll
keep it by the porch ♪
♪ And I'm walking at night ♪
♪ I'm like, whoa, it's
scary in the garden ♪
♪ In the yard ♪
♪ But it's powered by the sunlight ♪
♪ It makes it kinda hard ♪
♪ I know you might use a battery, not AA ♪
♪ More like a C or D sized ♪
♪ Like the bra, hey ♪
♪ Fun though ♪
♪ I've got to shake it when it fails ♪
♪ Looking like a cop going in and I fail ♪
♪ To understand why it can't
charge from the solar rays ♪
♪ People gather it
renewable, like wahey ♪
♪ And what we going to
end up in this world ♪
♪ If we don't get rid
of the fossil fuels ♪
♪ In the past they were like ♪
♪ We won't even have to worry ♪
♪ The Great Depression, the 1930s ♪
♪ They never asked
themselves the question ♪
♪ What would it be like if a
superstore moved out west ♪
♪ In the Dust Bowl ♪
♪ Maybe company that knows best ♪
♪ Fuck K-Mart and Costco ♪
♪ I'm talking about Walmart ♪
♪ Yeah, we all know ♪
♪ The greatest people helping you ♪
♪ Maybe greeting at the door saying ♪
♪ "Hi, welcome to the Dust Bowl store" ♪
♪ You got to understand
this horrible dust ♪
♪ Sand coming everywhere ♪
♪ All the metal it rusts ♪
♪ And people sitting outside ♪
♪ They be like, "I need food" ♪
♪ And Walmart in there ♪
♪ They're like, "Well,
we're kind of rude" ♪
♪ We won't let you have it for free ♪
♪ Surely they should give it away ♪
♪ Like a food pantry ♪
♪ Walmart, hey ♪
♪ I know maybe in the 2030s ♪
♪ Hundred years on ♪
♪ This'll be the situation
that we got going on ♪
♪ Sorry to East Hampton moms ♪
♪ That you're not in the rap ♪
♪ Apologies ♪
♪ Get excited ♪
♪ You be clapping up that, like ♪
♪ Yeah, he shouted out ♪
♪ It really pleased us ♪
♪ Let's address the fact ♪
♪ Kind of weird that Jews for
Jesus are a thing that exist ♪
♪ I know that he was Hasidic ♪
♪ They put him on the cross ♪
♪ They were like, don't quit it ♪
♪ You're born as a Jew ♪
♪ But died as a Christian ♪
♪ It's kind of different
because one's got no foreskin ♪
♪ The other one is more intact ♪
♪ We do the J.F.J here in the rap ♪
♪ All the Romans there ♪
♪ They would pick at his ribs ♪
♪ And at his shoes and say ♪
♪ "Ha ha, you're the king of the Jews" ♪
♪ He's like "Well, that's kind of mean ♪
♪ Put me on the cross" ♪
♪ Jews for Jesus though ♪
♪ They're like, no, he is our boss ♪
♪ I know we got Moses and
Isaac and the others ♪
♪ But Jesus, he's the best yet ♪
♪ Best of the brothers ♪
♪ And we can all discover ♪
♪ This, I'm really trying ♪
♪ I'm not an agriculturist,
but studying the science ♪
♪ I'm not a little vegan,
so you know I eat meat ♪
♪ I'm like, how does a cow? ♪
♪ How does a beef? ♪
♪ It confuses me ♪
♪ I've got a lot to sit with my thoughts ♪
♪ And I think about the beef hypothesis ♪
♪ What's it even mean? ♪
♪ Got the meat on the brain ♪
♪ Beef science maybe
studying the methane ♪
♪ Coming out the cows' backside ♪
♪ That's a natural gas ♪
♪ Beef science, funny word ♪
♪ That's a natural
laugh coming out of me ♪
♪ I'm so full ♪
♪ I see that animal ♪
♪ I see that bull ♪
♪ I put it in an automobile
and drive it far ♪
♪ I'm off to Afghani Capital ♪
♪ In the Ka-bul ♪
♪ Get it ♪
♪ I know it's spelled differently ♪
♪ They're kind of diffident ♪
♪ They're withdrawing currently ♪
♪ Trump, then Biden ♪
♪ We're like withdraw troops ♪
♪ People in Afghanistan
were feeling cock-a-hoop ♪
♪ All the Taliban ♪
♪ They had the plan to
take over the place ♪
♪ The regions and the capitals ♪
♪ It got egg on their face ♪
♪ Why it took about two
months for it to fall ♪
♪ I'm genuinely worried
for the people of Kabul ♪
♪ And other places ♪
♪ I'm like Kandahar ♪
♪ They lost a lot of lives in
the past is not ha ha funny ♪
♪ But someone said it ♪
♪ You cannot plan ♪
♪ Do a freestyle rap about Afghanistan ♪
♪ And so we'll say thoughts with them ♪
♪ Please don't die ♪
♪ Don't get killed ♪
♪ But there we go ♪
♪ A freestyle rap ♪
♪ I hope I left you thrilled ♪
(beat continues)
(audience cheers)